[Music]
[Music]
clap you people clap
every last one of you
happy wednesday everyone we've got a
great show tonight i'm not kidding jamie
lissau is back if he was any smarter or
cuter he'd be me
and kellyanne conway is here i'm so
excited just hearing her name has jim
acosta clutching his zoloft
but we're going to do something
different tonight
wow that sounds like cat when she found
that cardboard box full of doll heads
no tonight i'm going to bore you to
tears seriously why should colbert and
kimmel be the only ones allowed to do
that on late night tv
yes this segment is on
[Music]
hold on don't touch that remote where
you going stick around we're going to do
some fun stuff in the next block i
promise
okay fine before we get to the ethanol
here's hillary refusing to answer
questions as to whether her presidential
campaign spied on former president
donald trump
did you pay to spy on the trump campaign
what are you going to comment on the
spying allegations hillary
did you pay for the having spied on
hillary anything just hillary hillary
wow
that was great
as you know it's alleged that lawyers
from hillary's campaign in 2016 paid to
access servers belonging to trump tower
and later the white house in order to
establish a narrative to bring to
federal government agencies that would
link donald trump to russia but even
though hillary wouldn't answer questions
on that she managed to tweet saying
quote trump and fox desperately spinning
up a fake scandal to distract us from
his real ones
so it's a day that ends in y
well look pantsuit nobody had to spun
this up it didn't come from fox and
friends or mar-a-lago or from kim
jong-un's butthole
it came from john durham's investigation
so no wonder you're pleading for the
media to circle their wagons around you
because you pushed russian collusion
non-stop and now it turns out you were
the colluders all along
i'd call them creeps but why offend
brian kilmeade
so we're going to get to that but first
ethanol
yeah i'm like a parent making you eat
the broccoli before you get the pudding
or in cat's case lithium
here's a brand new nexio
boring but important the most important
story you will hear tonight that no one
else bothered to report because it makes
everyone look stupid except for people
like greg who were right all along
yes
ethanol as you know is made from corn or
as liz warren calls it maize
and for years it's been mixed into
gasoline to be sold at america's gas
pumps i know imagine something no one
wanted being forced on you the reason it
was better for the planet so corn that
would normally go to feed millions of
people around the globe or tyrus for a
week instead would fill your gas tank
but get this now it turns out that
ethanol is likely a much bigger
contributor to global warming than
straight gasoline according to a new
study yep everything they told us about
ethanol and climate was just like
russian collusion covington kavanaugh
the origins of kovid and what's really
inside geraldo's mustache
it's all bs
yep it's yet another liberal fantasy
that causes the opposite of its goal
like government spending fixing poverty
or the daily show inspiring laughter
it's all from a study published in the
proceedings of the national academy of
sciences it's where i used to work
before they caught me abusing a beaker
and it contradicts previous research
showing ethanol is a green energy source
now scientists find that like joe biden
in a porta potty ethanol is no friend to
the climate in fact it's at least 24
more carbon intensive than gas
of course the ethanol trade lobby
trashed the study and why wouldn't they
they're the ethanol trade lobby not the
society for saving you money to spend on
gas station snacks like those amazing
lance toast cheese sandwich crackers
with real peanut butter
no am i the only one
all right well this has been a cash cow
for the lobby and farmers got paid for
the corn whether it really worked or not
so it's truly a green source of energy
our oil of refiners must mix some 15
billion gallons of corn based ethanol
into our gas supply every year even to
eric swalwell it's a lot of gas
the president used taxpayer dollars to
ask the ukrainians to help them cheat an
election
look we got to make ethanol interesting
somehow but while the policy pretended
to reduce emissions it turned into a
giant subsidy for corn growers and this
mandate forced additional acres of land
to be used for cultivating the corn
which otherwise would have been used to
feed people meanwhile this tilling cat
this tilling of the fields released more
carbon from the soil while nitrogen
fertilizers also produced emissions dear
lord this is the most research i've done
since i decided to soundproof my
basement love den
i did so much research i even uncovered
this long lost video from the corn lobby
corn it's one of the most versatile
crops in the world
sure you know it as the food your wife
makes but did you know that today's
brightest minds have come up with
hundreds of other uses
for example a can of corn makes a great
doorstop shucks that door won't budge no
east germans getting in here that's
right and a can of corn can also be used
as a blunt murder weapon
[Music]
corn is also great for improving
communication don't forget to hold it up
to your ear we know how you ladies love
to talk and vacuuming all day hides the
pain
and after a long game of all-white
basketball corn oil is a light and
refreshing beverage yeah
tasty huh why do you put this in
gasoline
because shut the [ __ ] up commie
[Music]
good job researchers so what's the moral
here that everyone is full of poop and
not even corn filled poop especially
climate experts lobbyists and
politicians while you struggle to fill
your gas tank they're filling their bank
accounts forcing us to subsidize a
product as worthless as charlie sheen's
guide to proper dental care
for years we were told to buy this crap
but if we didn't we hated farmers
although i admit i never cared for mr
green jeans
even at 10 i wasn't buying it
meanwhile the price of corn rose for
everyone because our gas tanks were now
the primary client not our stomachs and
like gas tanks the cost to fill them
went up too we were fine we could eat
other stuff
hell i supplement my diet with rare
ocelots i'm that rich
but for poor countries corn became more
expensive did anyone starve who knows
there's no wikipedia page for that but
at least our air was better here except
it wasn't so there you go like cnn's
programming or russian collusion or
maroon 5's music ethanol subsidies and
politics in general is all garbage
now if you're still awake i hope you
enjoyed this boring moment now back to
our regularly scheduled programming and
that gorgeous hunk greg gutfeldt
[Applause]
welcome
tonight's guest
her time at the podium had democrats
reaching for modium former senior
counselor to president trump and author
of the new memoir here's the deal
kellyanne conway
excuse me
this alaskan can't even get a sea lion
to clap actor writer and comedian jamie
lassau
she's like a glow stick bright colorful
and found on floors at raves fox news
contributor cat tim
and his shirt size has more x's than kim
kardashian my massive sidekick and the
nwa world television champion tyrus
kellyanne welcome to the show thank you
you know what i decided to do you know
when you have people over for dinner and
you find out that somebody's a
vegetarian you always make sure there's
a vegetarian option and so when i was
doing this monologue on ethanol i'm
going i should really have an option for
people that want to talk about an
interesting story
yes no i wanted to instead inserted the
hillary piece because i wanted to get
your opinion
on that story now that the durham report
comes out and she's called she wanted to
call it fake news but that term was
already invented so she said fake
scandal what do you make of this whole
turnabout now that she's on the defense
sounds like the 62 percent of americans
who right before the 2016 election said
she was neither honest or trustworthy
were onto something
because they still feel that way and if
she's got nothing to hide she can just
ignore it but she what she ignored was
the daily mail reporter's questions
yesterday which were very pointed did
you or did you not
pay for
this fake scandal now i didn't pay i
would have just said no thank you have a
nice day
so it so i think what's happening is
that they are caught long after the fact
doing exactly what they accused us of
doing i was at the campaign i was in the
white house apparently they're
surveilling both jake sullivan is now
the national security director for the
country he's the guy who went out to the
podium last week and told the whole
world
what was going to happen in ukraine as
goes the united states involvement
that's the guy that hillary kept
retweeting right and he said we have
this great connection now between the
server and the set and the other but i
mean it's it's really joe biden who's
given us the russia collusion um putin's
never had a better friend between
nordstrom 2 and
obviously the 100 000 troops on the
russia ukraine border to say nothing of
his own pipeline killed the pipelines
here
and gave him his own pipeline but
hillary sort of she's like a bad penny
she never really truly goes away
and you would need 99 more of her to
even make a dollar
i hear all these rumors she may run for
office again i really hope she does
because we already know how we already
know how to beat her and i will say one
thing about hillary clinton she never
truly does anything to benefit anybody
other than hillary clinton she wakes up
every morning
as the second most popular person in a
two-person household that's rough yes
and then as the day goes on we realize
where's the hillary clinton center for
women and girls
we know where the bill's running it yes
yeah bill has one of those but no
seriously what has she done for anyone
of note that she has leveraged her power
her fundraising prowess her position to
help anyone other than blaming everyone
for a loss she's never truly fully
conceded and stayed that way but i think
they got caught here and it's worth
examining twitter's uh twitter's lit up
greg with why are we talking about
hillary clinton what are you going to
impeach her now they're also they're so
obsessed with trump they got rid of him
they can't quit him yes so let's have at
it with hillary i think it's worth
investigating 45 million for mueller to
tell us absolutely nothing i'll put in
45 to investigate this i'm with you i
think it'll be a great summer jamie
you have a choice you can have the
option of talking about hillary or the
option the option of ethanol i wonder
did you write jokes about ethanol well
first of all i wanted to say i do not
want to have at it with hillary
um
so i'll move over to the ethanol
i learned something from that last
segment as i was watching it i learned
that fart noises are always funny
except when they're real
that is true i mean always funny unless
it's like yeah but um
dude
this is fascinating i have to admit like
i did learn a lot like reading about
this and i'm glad that finally like this
information is out as you kind of threw
out there and it ends up being true for
real but damn corn has a kick-ass
publicist yes it does oh my god like
corn was in everything like it if you
look at the corn syrup and you look at
how and then but when one day somehow
they go hey what about corn
flavored gas yes some guy was like i'm
listening that's insane
it's the craziest thing ever and then i
did look at because you know there's
always
opinions on both sides and i looked at
you know they're like this says that
it's much worse for the environment than
if we just straight up when we got but
you know you got to look and i did find
like in 2019 there was a study that said
like a little bit of the arguing to the
opposite but i went deeper into it and
it turned out that study was done by
corn yes yes there you go but very
fascinating very fascinating tyrus which
story would you like to concentrate on i
too don't want to have at it with
hillary
i guess
you remember that old movie that we're
all well we're also underwater by now
the inconvenient truth right i think
we're finding with liberals that truth
is inconvenient i really think they need
to switch that title because pretty much
everything that they've predicted
although we still have aoc's two
predictions we'll be down to cat we got
like what seven years
seven years left yeah and then democracy
ends just shortly after the world which
is weird because which is weird so just
when the cockroaches take over yes
democracy falls out and then they're
just up in their little arms because
what they're gonna do because you have
socialist crickets now taking over
what's left of the world so we have all
that to go for i just at some point
somebody has to just whenever they talk
go
stop just
go sit down no more because they're
always
wrong and when they're wrong and you
call them on it
you're a racist so it's like you can't
even have a conversation with him like
hey look i've been there i've been doing
the numbers on the corn thing it looks
like racist no no i'm not a racist i
just want you to know that this is
actually going to be sexist no i'm
trying to tell you that there's
something cancel him he's gone and
that's it you can't it's it's craziness
because you cannot
talk to somebody who already has all the
answers and they're wrong well and also
because every every object in life
becomes political even corn cat you are
as a libertarian probably going like duh
because this is something that
libertarians have been talking about
forever i mean rand paul has been
talking about this and yeah when
listened it's so shocking it's something
that things would be better if the
government just didn't do anything right
and it's another example of something
that it said needed to be done for the
common good of everyone but it turned
out to be a big scam and unfortunately i
feel most people learn the wrong lesson
from this if they pay any attention
which most won't but even if they do say
oh the government needs to make
different choices and do different
things i think she needs to do fewer
things yes well pj work you know he
passed away yesterday and you know he he
had i'm paraphrasing but it was along
the lines of like it's not a libertarian
isn't about you know politics it's about
getting rid of politics yes getting
politic politics out of everything
absolutely we ended up getting putting
politics politics in our oil our
gasoline and our food yes and everywhere
i want to add one more thing jamie that
fart was real yes oh my god i'm just i'm
i i i really i'm very passionate about
i'm very passionate about the fact that
he did fart yeah this is something that
she did not know
i did a deep dive on ethanol she did a
deep dive on gas
i've been researching that for uh since
he farted and uh
actually the only real thing in the
segment because he played what he was
saying again he was lying about the call
of duty
the only honest thing that came out of
swalwell was a fart i'm writing a book
about it
i looked it up and it turns out corn is
in more things than kevin hart that's
how
a lot oh stuff he is a lot of stuff oh i
thought that was a sex joke liberals oh
no he's in a lot of movies and no i love
kevin hart all right we got to move on
glad we cleared that up they're just
like the new coke you know the democrats
are just new coke and they want it to
stay actually hillary being the same
topic along with corn made corn very
exciting to me
thank you at least you know it's corn
i'm really hungry hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else